Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar. This classic problem is making the rounds because it it easy to state
but evidently, it's extremely hard for adults to solve.
Can you figure it out?
The problem is to make 3 squares of equal size by moving 3 of the sticks.
The problem is like it sounds, there are no other tricks.
You are not allowed to break any of the sticks,
the 3 resulting squares must be of equal size,
and each stick in the resulting shape must be part of a square.
Give the problem a try and when you're ready, keep watching the video for the solution
The only difficult part is selecting which sticks to move
Here is one possible solution
On our first move we will move this stick
This will be our second move
And this will be our third move
And what we have is a shape that has
Three squares of equal sides
Now due to the symmetry of the problem you could have also found this
by moving three other sticks
you may have also come up with the same shape upside down
But this is the basic solution
Did you figure it out?
Thanks for watching this video, please subscribe to my channel I make videos on math and game theory
You can catch me of my blog at ''MindYourDecisions'' which you can follow on
Facebook, Google+ and Patreon
You can catch me on social media @preshtalwalkar
And if you liked my video please check out my books there are in the video description.